más
espero que ahora tengas una mejor idea
de cómo funciona el promedio ponderado
con dos puntos y tres puntos a
continuación veremos qué sucede cuando
reemplazamos el paso de hacer el
promedio usando puntos medios con
promedios ponderados aquí estamos otra
vez con el interactivo de subdivisión de
curvas excepto que ahora tenemos este
deslizador que nos permite cambiar los
pesos utilizados para hacer el promedio
el 11 de aquí significa que estamos
haciendo un promedio directo entonces
voy a dividir como siempre al insertar
puntos medios y al hacer el promedio
mueve el punto hacia el punto medio más
cercano de la derecha
observa lo que sucede cuando cambian los
pesos a 21
generalicemos ahora con el caso de los
promedios de 3 puntos observa lo que
pasa cuando cambio los pesos a 121 y
ahora vuelvo a dividir como antes pero
cuando aplicó el promedio cada punto se
moverá hacia la posición correspondiente
con el peso 2 el punto cercano de la
izquierda con el peso 1 y el cercano de
la derecha con el peso 1
este punto deberá moverse hacia acá como
vimos en el ejemplo sobre promedio
ponderado y si dividimos y promediamos
de nuevo se ve así
el siguiente ejercicio te dará más
práctica con la idea de subdivisiones
ponderadas buena suerte